E aí
[Música]
a avó Taj Meu nome é Maicon Andrade
tenho 41 anos sou ciumenta para estar
bem depois do nascimento do meu filho
não trocou agora só o pai de José Luiz a
Olá eu sou um menino apaixonado e saiu
do que mista com a transformação digital
o mercado stahnke individualismo nos
últimos seis anos eu quase que viciei
nisso e comecei a consumir que formar a
braço todo literatura sobre
empreendedorismo de transformação
digital e inovação
e também pode ser feito os principais
programas de aceleração destaques e dos
eventos de empreendedorismo estatais da
América Latina ou como Startup sem
acelerado ou como a vereador e
acelerador status e o que eu percebi
esses seis anos de ecossistema
desagradáveis que você tá bom que existe
uma fórmula dos principais ecossistemas
de sucesso dos dados no mundo falar um
pouquinho sobre a trajetória nesses seis
anos eu participei dos principais
processos no Brasil se o satélite que
recentemente eu fiz uma imersão no Vale
do Silício eu queria trazer para vocês
dividido em três ecossistemas o que eu
criei como o Pilar do ecossistema está
trabalho
e quais são os três pilares que na minha
opinião transformam ecossistema Startup
em um ecossistema de sucesso e
eu vou começar falando da Startup Chile
desculpa vou começar a falar do Brasil é
claro eu tô aqui começar a falar do
Brasil pois eu falar um pouco sobre o
Chile na figura que está cheia depois
sobre o passe livre começando pelo
Brasil a
e em 2019 o Brasil ficou em terceiro
lugar no ranking dos estados que mais
criou e fornos no mundo sério unicórnio
seu status que valem mais de 1 bilhão de
dólares e o Brasil mesmo com todas as
características que nós conhecemos ficou
em terceiro lugar no mundo em criação
está táxi não
nós ficamos à frente de sistemas
riquíssimos como ecossistema europeu e
Oi e o tenho percebido ecossistema
descartáveis leva sistema de
empreendedorismo no Brasil que esse
ecossistema se divide em
micro-ecossistema por característica
eles são independentes são fascistas são
isolados não fica isso vou dar alguns
exemplos começa a por Minas Gerais e na
telinha em
em Minas nós temos o programa City
programa incrível temos a fracos como
maxmilhas médicos with Startup bom para
o estado do Espírito Santo tem que ter
uma bastante Wine e uma iniciativa
incrível chamada frente leve podemos ver
para o Recife ponto digital considerado
comum por muitos como o melhor parque
tecnológico do Brasil mas inclusive eles
micro-ecossistema seu encontro uma
característica em comum entre eles
o governo capital privado pessoas ou eu
posso chamar de talentos e
a todos esses himiko ecossistemas e o
conheci outros como que São Paulo com do
Rio Grande do Sul que eu tenho um grande
orgulho ter participado conhecemos
tratar chamado de morango foi medida
pelo iFood todos esses ecossistemas
encontrei essa característica governo
capital privado e pessoas tá limpo sem
uma simbiose lá nem ser perfeita mas
ativamente a presença dos três estavam
lá ok atravessando a Cordilheira dos
Andes lá do outro lado encontro Chile
chipotle característica uma faixa de
terras no continente lá em cima muito
calor lá embaixo muito frio e tem como
principal riqueza do seu filho e
mineração
o que o governo que suportem que vai
ficar aí você tem criar novas formas de
Indra
bom e como solução para diversificar e
criar novas formas de renda orando pelo
programa batizado de Startup Chile
objetivo do programa é simples é que lhe
abraçar as formas de quebrar essa essa
resistência que o chileno tem sobre
inovação tirar ele da zona do conforto e
principalmente fomentar o
empreendedorismo
o programa funciona da seguinte forma o
governo financia parte do programa
entrega logística EA infraestrutura e
desbloquia Boro enfim para ver quebra a
burocracia de se criar uma empresa em 24
horas você tem sua empresa criada você
tem sua conta aberta e você pode começar
a faturar além da conexão que eles fazem
que ele faz com as principais empresas e
ainda capital privado uma parte do
financiamento vem do governo outra parte
do financiamento do Capital privado
Empresas Grandes Empresas como latam
Michelin BC e investem na Startup Chile
coloca um dinheiro e mais do que isso
disponibilizam seus principais
inventores gestores executivos para
trabalhar diariamente com essas
stathacos educando ensinando o que é uma
venda ensinando o que é um financeiro
ensinando o que é uma exportação Opa
Observe temos aí a
o governo e do Capital privado
bom e o que tá faltando aqui pessoas eu
comecei falando que objetivo dessa
tapete era justamente quebrar esse
estatuscor da mente Lena do conforto do
não querendo o vaso não querer sair
daquilo que ele já estão acostumados e
fomentar a Inovação pois bem Está tapete
lhe convidar pessoas do mundo inteiro a
participarem do programa Startup da
Grécia da Ucrânia da Espanha do Canadá
Estados Unidos vão para o Chile
participou durante 10 meses vivendo no
Chile junto com as cartas chilenas do
programa de aceleração da Startup Chile
ou servem de novo não é que o sistema de
sucesso nós temos governo nós temos
capital privado nós temos pessoas
talentos dentro do mesmo ambiente
e agora vamos falar de outro ecossistema
talvez a mais folclórico deles Vale do
Silício
o que me conhecido como BR
o porquê que o vale conseguiu criar mais
200 Startup sem um ano o que levou a
este lugar ser tão fértil no
desenvolvimento de status eu tive a
oportunidade de ir para lá em dezembro
fazer uma invenção no vale e o que eu
identifiquei aí minha percepção
e é que ele também possui os três
pilares mas para falar sobre isso a
gente vai ter que dar uma volta e lá no
passado em 1957 para falar da corrida
espacial 11957 a antiga União Soviética
e Estados Unidos começaram a correr para
saber quem seria preciso primeiro
primeiro país a levar uma expansionary
uma espaçonave tripulada para obter
Planetário e mais do que isso quem seria
o primeiro país a levar um homem à lua
e depois de vários sucessivos sucessos
da União Soviética em colocar um homem
no espaço em 1961 de John Kennedy em
frente o congresso americano fez uma
promessa a todo o povo americano que
Estados Unidos seria o primeiro país do
mundo a levar um homem à lua se ele
sabia como fazer isso ou não naquela
naquele dia eu realmente não sei mas
posterior essa promessa uma avalanche de
dinheiro centenas de milhares de dólares
foram investidos em universidades e em
grupo de pesquisa governos Peugeot
centenas de milhares de Dólares
principalmente na Califórnia no Vale do
Silício na busca da solução de Como
levar um homem à lua
o posterior é isso esse virou uma rotina
e até os dias de hoje o governo continua
injetando centenas de milhares de
Dólares Principalmente quando a gente
fala de armamento bélico nas
universidades e nos centros de Pesquisas
americanos
a todos os meses todos os dias isso
o jogo temos mais um pilar governo não
só desburocratizando agora conseguir
falar como injetando centenas de
milhares de Dólares em centros de
pesquisa
e na outra ponta logo depois do Sucesso
de levar um homem à lua 1961 começou foi
a promessa de Kennedy depois o homem foi
a lua a Califórnia tava rica
Oi e o Novo Movimento começou a surgir
ali nos Estados Unidos em especial na
Califórnia em especial no Vale do
Silício uma nova transformação que nos
levou o momento atual de transformação
digital começou acontecer e as empresas
perceberam que se ela colocasse dinheiro
capital privado em ideias malucas que
por muito eram que eram ideias que
jamais chegarem ao Sucesso Ela poderia
se tornar um unicórnio valer mais de um
bilhão e mesmo com a taxa de mais de
noventa porcento de mortalidade entre as
startups valeria a pena investir um
dinheiro nessa nessas empresas e isso
que nós temos hoje dentro do vale uma
injeção diária de centenas de milhar de
idosos de Capital privado em ideias que
por muitos são considerados como a Lucas
como você tá uma Uber
A amb
um beijo governo e agora capital privado
numa simbiose promovendo inovação Mas
faltam Pilar e esse Pilar que para mim o
mais importante em todo ecossistema que
sem ele não adianta o pessoas
e a sonda na rua que você entende por
que que a Califórnia é o que é pequeno
vale é o que é em poucos minutos você
escuta vários idiomas identifica
identifica várias nacionalidades pessoas
do mundo inteiro extremamente
qualificados vão provar em busca do
sangue Startup Em Busca do Sonho do
unicórnio Então você tem governo capital
privado e pessoas extremamente
qualificados dentro do mesmo ambiente
com panela de pressão perfeita para que
você cria um ambiente de desenvolvimento
de unicórnios
e para concluir
e na minha visão opinião Mike meu CPF de
baixo
e para que um ecossistema de inovação
empreendedorismo funcione ele precisa de
três pilares
Ah e quanto melhor essa harmonia Entre
esses Pilares mais bem-sucedido será
esse ecossistema primeiro governo
comentando a Inovação valorizando o
empreendedor e colocando no mercado cada
vez e cada vez mais projetos de inovação
e Tecnologia
o segundo capital privado também
financiando a Inovação mentor ando os
novos empreendedores e mais do que isso
dando oportunidade de fazer negócio com
startups que querem provar a sua ideia
a e por último definitivamente o mais
importante pessoas precisamos valorizar
Mentes Brilhantes precisamos dores a
ideias precisamos fomentar o
empreendedorismo entender que isso não é
algo romântico mas sem álcool deve ser
educar lá na escola e deve ser ensinado
no jardim de infância e na faculdade
de 100 pessoas nada disso seria possível
não podemos confinar Mentes Brilhantes a
processos tradicionais precisamos criar
ambientes que são colaborativo e
principalmente em ambientes que quebram
status Corre que permita que essas
pessoas que têm mentes criativas possam
estrapolar ainda mais suas ideias
e esse é o recado que eu deixo para
vocês Muito obrigado pela oportunidade
boa noite